dude so season finale of The Bachelor of
Arts yeah
goddamn it they stretch footage like ooh
they stretch footage harder than that
girl who who put that gigantic dildo in
her ass stretches her [ __ ] it's crazy
they milk the same ten seconds of
footage for 30 minutes I couldn't
believe it it's pretty it's pretty
genius it's impressive
it really is so thinking and that means
stupid people to watch the same thing
over and over again and they're just
like and then just fill it with ads yeah
like unreal dude people complain when I
put a few mid rolls in a in a 20 minute
video yeah watch The Bachelor hours in
to edit watch The Bachelor Bachelor
watch some copy and paste the same edit
five [ __ ] times and then put six ads
in between each one
yeah it's crazy and people and all 80%
of America just sits turned and yeah
it's it up yeah it's like man I was
dying laughing dude could that anyone
first of all this dude is crying so much
that's what happens when you're a virgin
you cry okay cuz like you have you've
never been the nut has to come out
somewhere yeah it's like it's all you're
all pent up and this guy used to be a
football player too so it's just bad for
him he's got high test you know yeah
yeah milk coming out of your eyes what
the [ __ ] is crying crying come we
squirting out of your eyes oh [ __ ] it's
shooting out of his [ __ ] cornea what
[Laughter]
yes oh this man is crying all the time
so basically he's got three girls left
two of them about his age one of them
young like 23 the young one rejects him
okay she ends it she cuts it off she's
like you know wait on the finale it was
like last week okay got you you know she
ends it cuz she couldn't like it's the
funniest [ __ ]
the dude goes so I just want to let you
know that when I spoke to your father he
did not give me his blessing and she's
like I just thought my family would
trust me and I think that's something
you would have wanted to tell me sooner
now I'm just really confused and it's
like all this drama and I could imagine
everyone being like yeah yeah yeah like
no [ __ ] dude you've been on this show
what three four weeks yeah you left like
I'm gonna go on this John the bachelor
you come back a month later and you're
like some getting married of course any
sane dad is named like [ __ ] no oh
absolutely
it's all so dumb for her to be like I
thought my family would trust me exactly
yeah reality show find a husband yeah
well apparently while this was airing
there was a another show that I don't
know why she was shooting the show
another show is airing where she was
like another dating show so she's very
clearly just trying to get on TV oh oh
she's on it yeah she was like on another
show like dating another guy oh my god
so whatever so and then I guess the
drama was during the season that she was
saying like I don't know if I'm ready
for marriage and then the girls that
wanted to marry him try to tell him like
yo that [ __ ] ain't ready she's lying to
you and it's every every season it
always goes down like that like the
girls were really about it but they're
like 28 mm-hmm you know and then it's
always like the young chick who's not
ready and it dudes I was like no she so
hot she I mean she could be ready she
said she could be ready I can convince
her to be ready he's just so hot I just
can't now she'll be ready dude she'll be
trust me man you won't sure you don't
your old ass to know what you're talking
about
I'm your age shut the [ __ ] up grandma
she can be read it's just like such dude
[ __ ] just totally believing this horse
[ __ ]
and so she says you know I just don't
know if I'm ready and I don't have my
father's blessings
I just don't be I want you to have yeah
that's why it's your father's blessing
yes Larry I want you to have what you
want which is just the best way to tell
I'm not into you I want you to have what
you want hmm
yeah no I'm doing this for you yeah yeah
this is a I don't you don't I don't
deserve you yes you're so good I want
you to be happy and I'm not gonna make
you happy and which is funny because
that's the same speech he gave the other
girls so he breaks down and he does like
this [ __ ] super juvenile [ __ ] where
he's like I'm done all right I want
we're ending the show I'm done and he
just he just like starts to walk away
from the set and they're like Carlton
stop and then he hops a fence and
they're like oh my god yeah dude that
I've seen that clip it's like he just
hopped that [ __ ] face that happened
last season no no no but they always do
their new [ __ ] now is yes finding the
unscripted [ __ ] and making it are like
scripting unscripted [ __ ] and making it
seem like it's unscripted
yeah that's their new [ __ ] yeah well
what happened last season with the with
the with the fight yeah it was seemed
like a fight yeah the dude rolled over
in his sleep and like fell through a
table no not that I mean the one of the
last episodes where he breaks it off
with the girl that he proposed to or
whatever oh yeah
word fight at the end of the show yeah
awkward conversation yeah yeah that dude
already he he proposed to a girl and
then and then he took it back took it
back and then went to another girl it's
the same [ __ ] yeah they do that now
every [ __ ] time they find these
moments where the producers like yes
this is good because if something if
some [ __ ] like unpredictable [ __ ]
happens where he jumps a fence people go
apeshit for that yeah well that that
seems to be the progressing thing
because like it was hilarious as the
host again first of all he can't steak
you could tell the the scripting is just
do not not mention his virginity is
always like Chris Harris it like the
dramatic cliff will play and he goes the
studio silent everyone's crying he's
like that moment was as hard to watch as
it was to experience I can attest to
that what happens now what happens to
Colton in his proposal even more
important his virginity find out when we
come back and it's just like
you said that you saw like these two
girls like break like they're like what
man what it's like almost verbatim he's
had enough dude yeah
walk up our show go [ __ ] yourself in
virgi [ __ ]
well that's the best part so you have to
the fence and it you hear all these PAS
going oh my god you have to fence call
tent Colton and then just cut dude it
cuts to Chris he goes oh my god he just
hopped that [ __ ] fence it's like yeah
oh [ __ ] and like how do we get it open
and they can't figure out how to get it
open for like 30 seconds then someone
like it's a [ __ ] remote and it just
slowly opens and then the lack like he's
gone the last gone forever
if there is no scent no that's what's
hilarious about it everyone has a sense
of urgency - Chris the host he's just
like hands and pockets he just like kind
of like shuffles through the fence as
its opening he goes wow he's gone I
don't know where you went this is crazy
yeah that's crazy this is like out of
here sparks a blunt yeah they like then
they get these clips listen I bet these
Bible bangers won't [ __ ] with his eyes
[ __ ] he's really gone oh I gotta go look
for him let me face this [ __ ] real quick
look at that roach somebody picked that
up dude I can guarantee you before they
started shooting that scene they're like
alright when he jumps the fence all the
PAS you got a shout oh my god just
seemed like you're actually like oh yeah
or even if they 80-yard it in yeah yeah
probably yeah no dude what it's so let's
come back again when he's like storming
off he's like got like this little kid
face like I like he's like pushing his
lips on his tongue in you like you're
like musha's a camera like
in a way but it's the most gentle like
alright I know this thing's like sixty
thousand dollars so I'm just gonna
gently yeah yeah I'm just gonna tap stop
it just kind of like a then he goes on
these stairs there's some miscellaneous
object it's like some wooden toy that he
just smacks it's like it's just the
least angry thing is like Virgin anger
right there yeah that's what that is
yeah holdin back holdin I don't need sex
you know yeah so then he soon he gets
about a block away and they make it this
dramatic thing and then he's like I'm
done I'm done and Chris Leak so you want
to call off the whole thing you think
yeah I do I'm done because a 23 year old
wouldn't marry you yeah yeah you're a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]